this is a production of Cornell
University
Thanks thank you
well thank you it's been it's a real
pleasure to be here and it's really nice
to be right after Paul because Paul's
really and his team has done have done a
really great piece of work they continue
to do good work so but first I did want
to kind of mention a lot of people
wonder what this long island thing is
and I did want to mention that we do
have a research station down in Long
Island right riverhead on the eastern
portion of Long Island been there 94
years we're getting ready to celebrate
100th anniversary in about six six more
years but we're in Suffolk County here
which is the eastern almost two-thirds
of the island and we're very diverse
agricultural country most people don't
know that so whenever I go out to speak
I like to make sure that the people
understand that we have a lot of
Agriculture out there and we're actually
a very the leading county in the state
of New York for crop agriculture as far
as the wholesale value so that's one of
the reasons that Cornell's down there if
you look at the total egg products were
number two now we used to be number one
to about three years ago but but still
we're number one for crop agriculture we
have more nurseries and more greenhouses
than a place else in the state of New
York vegetables are number five other
crops like potatoes were number one and
ducks and poultry we're still number one
so we have a lot of agriculture and
that's that's why we're down to Long
Island and we're very fortunate our
research center were the only one in the
country that has specialists for each of
the commodity zones we have floor
culture greenhouse specialists fruit
specialists particularly in the grapes
because we bought it we about 2,000
acres of grapes of vegetable specialists
and then ornamental specialists and then
we're also very fortunate to have the
cross commodity specialist to plant
pathologist Marjorie's here today weed
scientists to entomologist so we're kind
of a one-stop shop and in in what what
is true theoretical extension our
stakeholders are about 50 mile radius
from us so we get to interact with them
all the time they bring in their
diseases and they bring in their insects
or we go visit them so that's what we do
down in Long Island
and also I unlike poem I'm not a
wildlife specialist I'm I'm a plant
breeder and greenhouse specialist and as
Margaret had mentioned earlier we we
have been breeding with the impatiens
and as of last year we came up with our
first to truly downy mildew resistant
patient's Marjorie and her team along
island also helped us was that research
we're currently working Yuki here in the
front row is work you're going to be
working with us for the next several
years on making that a seed line right
now if you're going to grow this you'd
have to propagate it by cuttings also
been working with ultra Mary for many
years on developing winter hardiness we
have several those dear love those by
the way so don't grow those if you have
deer and then we're also working on a
project of breeding vitex the chaste
tree nor grad student is up there and
he's been working on that project so
that gives you a little bit about that
but really what we're here to talk about
is deer and deer kind of more of my
hobby because i got i like the garden a
lot and so I've always lived in areas
that have had deer populations so you
know people think that they're very cute
they don't want to sometimes they don't
want to hunt them but for us on Long
Island deer are number one problem for
farmers as well as maybe the homeowners
out there they have nice gardens so
you know the original title of this talk
was deer resistant plants but you may
have noticed that I changed it to plants
that you're not do not eat because if
you use the term deer resistant you know
there is no plant that's resistant to
dear if a deer wants to bite it and chew
it it's going to certainly eat the plant
so like that little spruce up there you
know dear don't you don't eat the Spruce
but if they take a bite it's not
resistant it's not like iron so so no
plant is truly resistant of a deer wants
to eat it and you know we have other
problems as Paul mentioned to you know
the rubbing antler so if you do come up
with a garden with all these plants that
are resistant to dears then the next The
Deer the next thing you realize is that
in the fall the male deer come along and
they rub the the bark and they girdle
the trees and they kill them that way so
you know not only do they eat it then
they step on it you know you'll get all
kinds of physical damage i know our
boxwoods and our house has been jamming
you know they don't eat your don't eat
boxwoods but they will step on them when
they're trying to reach higher levels of
plant material to eat and then they do
cosmetic damage you know this is a
classic photo of our by t hedges on Long
Island they they just get devoured by
the deer and it's you know they just
nibble everything they can and then the
other part is that you know you're
walking through your garden and you step
it on all kinds of little presents that
they leave and so that that's not very
much fun either well the kind of
mentioned this earlier but there are a
lot of deer in the United States
according to a 2014 study there's 15
million dear and then as he also
mentioned we have other problems like
car accidents associated this was from
the insurance company online farmers you
know have immeasurable damage from the
from the deer and and of course you
knows there's a hosta so when I say
farmers I include the greenhouse flora
culture industry and then Lyme disease
and all kinds of other diseases you know
the disease now that makes you allergic
to meet you've heard about that one
right it's a true disease I thought it
was I thought it was a fairytale when I
first heard about it but last year we've
had so many people that have come down
with that disease now that they can't
eat any kind of meat protein so you know
dear do cause a lot of problems we put a
fence around our farm we have 68 acres
at the Extension Center at a cost of
about eighty thousand dollars we put a
fence around the entire farm and we'd be
out of business if we didn't have the
fence but as Paul mentioned you should
be about eight foot fence and then the
fence and the deer management or hunting
are the only ways you're actually going
to truly be sure that you're going to
get rid of your dear paul also mentions
repellents and you didn't mention Liquid
Fence power surprise because this is a
really good this is a really good
repellent we have tried this in several
situations deer out also these are two
that work very well Liquid Fence smells
really really bad badly so if you spray
it before a party people will stay away
from your house on the other hand dear
out smells like cloves it's very much
more pleasant so the other problem with
deer fence is that it's a very thick
mixture so when you put it in a spray
bottle it really clogs up the spray
bottle quickly so but they both work
dependably sure
well I've heard people say that but we
do have a nursery landscape environments
in Long Island which is a manitech New
York they have beautiful gardens that
are subject to deer attack and they they
consistently spray with one every week
and that's the other thing that we
didn't mention earlier probably
mentioned is that when he did that study
he sprayed once and then saw how things
were repelled for several months later
but if you're in a homeowner situation
you should you should reapply you know
because they will wash off dear we'll
get you know the smell will get less
unpleasant to the deer so I don't think
there's a that there's I don't think
there's any problem to rotating back and
forth from one to the other but I don't
think you necessarily need to because
we've tried areas of just liquid fence
and just deer out in this fight yes I'm
not sure what's what's in here but but
it smells really bad
so some
oh the question I think what the
question is do I find that these work
for buck rubbing also not really not
really we use fences I think I'll [ __ ]
well in just a couple of slides I'll
show you that there's different ways
we're going to talk about plants but
there's other ways you can do it and one
is choose to elevate your plants okay as
a homeowner we can do this of course in
the commercial business you can't these
are all pictures from my house but you
can see we put window boxes in where
they can't reach but I will say this
little little walkway in between the
house and the garage they have come into
there and eat in our plants in there so
there's no guarantees but you know the
we uses a hey the window boxes we use
hanging baskets where they can't reach
and then even on our hen house we put a
green roof on top of the hand house just
to make the mat you know because it can
and the hen house serves dual purpose
because not only is it a place where the
chickens to live but we let them out at
night and they eat ticks so you know
take the chickens are very good at tic
elimination but they'll get them all
because I will tell you I get every day
I'm out in the ground i get a tick so
and the other one is defense your plants
Paul mentioned that too but on a
homeowner situation we do that we fence
them in it looks really ugly but if you
want to rhododendron a Long Island you
better fence it or so it's going to be
eating typically what we do this is a
store dia that is fenced in it was a
very it was kind of a present and it had
sentimental meetings to us so we fenced
it in but this just this year it's been
big enough I thick enough that i don't
think the deer going to rub it and when
they start eating the lower part that's
okay they came to the lower part and
will enjoy the top part but and it's
also surrounded by bayberry which is one
of my plants that i'm going to be
talking about and when deer go to rub
they like to have a clear approach
entrance so with the bayberry hope that
is also going to kind of determine but
what we're going to talk about today is
choosing the right plants for the garden
because you can't have a beautiful
in spite of the point but in spite of
the deer situation this is another
picture from my garden we have a lot of
deer as I was amazed when Paul said 250
per perfect square mile most of them are
in my yard I'm sure so and I also want
to say I have a lot of faith in this
this list you should have all I passed
that Neil had passed out the list to
y'all you know I a lot of faith in that
let list and you'll notice that on the
list that we have the asterisks plants
those are what I call my ninety-five
percent plants that means ninety-five
percent of the time the deer won't touch
it but the reason we have faith in our
list is that we've actually done this in
a scientific manner we've replicated
these plants and different locations
that have deer pressure under control
situations the the deers for it so to
speak so I used to live in Connecticut
for 18 years we had Gardens there that
had a lot of deer and then we moved to
Long Island and so we've replicated
these and I feel very confident about
this list because my wife and I Margo we
both like to garden so we garden a lot
and in our situation we have a son
garden where we can test some plants and
then we have a shade garden woodland
garden where we can do woodland plants
and so we do replicate we have great
situations like one year Marjorie was
doing a study with junipers and she had
these Jennifer's left over and she said
you want to use these for deers this is
great so I took all these plants home
and I spread them around so we have
different locations on the property to
make sure that the deer had access to
them and we able able to judge them so
that's I just want to say that's why we
feel very confident about this list now
people always say this to me when I
speak at groups around the country
they're going to say well if a deer is
hungry enough they're going to eat
anything okay and you know there are
certain plants that are really poisonous
okay these are three plants I'll talk
about the foxglove the tour the the
monks or they're very poisonous plant if
we ate those plants we'd be dead if deer
eat those plants that they'd be dead so
they don't eat you know this is not
completely true
but I will believe what Paul said Paul
said that if you have such a high
pressure and that they're starving to
death they'll probably eat some of these
things I haven't seen us but you know
Long Island Connecticut isn't really a
situation where there are leather other
gardens to go to and they can eat other
plans so what I'm going to do today I
can't obviously talk about all the
plants on your list because we only have
a half an hour but but I want to talk
about some of the annuals and I'm going
to talk about some of the herbaceous
perennials actually more curvaceous
perennials because this group is more
interested in that and then some of the
woodies and we'll just talk until the
time's up you know you have to stop me
when my times up i'll just stop because
then this afternoon when we're out of
bluegrass lame will walk through the the
trial runs out there that their
perennial grains and we'll talk more
about perennials then I mean I'm sorry
about plants that are resistant to deer
and feel free to yell out any questions
you have as I go home but Cleo me or one
of these plants I think is if those of
you who are growers are have nurseries
you've probably seen this planet quite
popular in recent years particularly
some of the new new cultivars that have
been released the clam heroes a leader
for example a lot of that is being grown
probably not because it's deer resistant
but it is quite daily resistant but
because it's short it's compact it's
very floriferous that's a nice plant but
any of the Cleo me or spider flowers do
well their annuals these are the
Rosalita sterols don't won't recede
itself but these other the the clammy
Hassler anna will recede itself and it
will act as a perennial so even though
it's an annual it will continue to come
up for you every year a lot of people
don't try the color cages or the
allocations because they're kind of
expensive you know each one of those
those corns was about ten dollars twelve
dollars on Long Island $25 no no you
know we're about ten dollars on Long
Island but they're kind of pricey but
that's okay you know because you could
put out your garden and join for the
summer and actually dig them up I dig a
ball mine in the in the fall it's very
easy once they frost it down I just cut
them off dig them out shake all the soil
and then throw them on my base of it
it's it's not
doesn't freeze and and they just they
dry all winter then in the spring I take
them to plant them outside and they do
fine so even though expensive they do
work well the allocations the same way
kind of a nicer showy plant the leaves
the foliage is more upright in this case
but annual plants they don't fly they
just offer that foliage kind of
attractiveness nkosi an is an
interesting plant this isn't a co she
Anna silvestris it has the white plant
we've tried other nkosi anise the little
nkosi and the little tobacco's that are
so popular other species it seems to be
that this is the only species that
actually is resistant they won't touch
this plant and other tobacco's that
we've tried and tried several times they
will eat so I don't quite understand
that but this is what what we've noticed
this is another one of those annuals
that that will recede itself and come up
year after year as a perennial so if you
want this but it's a tall plant it gets
its tall and chewy and really nice and
in gardens and this is the plant that
does well in full Sun and also does well
in a partial shade situation the
pennisetum czar really nice ornamental
grasses I think I might talk about
another ornamental grass later is later
on in the presentation even though I
haven't been proud every grass that
there is I would be willing to say that
probably every grass every ornamental
grass is resistant to dear I've never
seen grasses eaten by dear the purple
fountain grass is really pretty it's an
annual you can see you can really make
some nice designs with coleus and other
kinds of allocations and other things to
make a nice pot or even a nice section
year garden but these you do need to
repurchase because they they are annuals
okay so those are my annuals just there
are other ones on your list let's move
into the herbaceous perennials I
mentioned earlier
that the monks would one of the most
poisonous plants there is every part of
that plants poisonous from the flowers
to the leaves to the roots and deer tend
to stay away from it I should also
mention that some plants that are
resistant will occasionally get nibbled
on that like this particular plant I
have several of these in our gardens and
I noticed that that at one point there
were the tops were nibbled off you have
to remember that your deal deer
population may be changing particularly
in the spring when you have all the baby
deer you know the young fawns walk you
through and they have not let your not
yet learned that these plants are
poisonous or don't taste well so they'll
take a little nibble and then you know
of course they damage your plant but
they're not going to eat the whole
planets they won't be back after that
after they take their first taste they
usually leave the plant alone agastache
very dependable plants this was also on
kanye's list for for pollinators this is
a very hardy perennial it smells very
nice might be the fragrance that these
leaves give off to keep the deer away a
lot of pollinators go to these plans to
I will say though if you grow this plant
it is I don't want to use the I word the
invasive word but it will spread a lot
in your garden so you have to be careful
about that it comes up here and there
but a great plant you can get in purples
and whites and blues the aliens are very
resistant to the deer it always kinds of
surprised me that plants like this which
we eat you know we find us culinary
plants the deer won't eat so they don't
touch it the garlic chives are
interesting however the garlic chives
for us down the long island are just
starting to bud that's the part actually
that you eat if you're going to use it
and cooking it you know before the
Flyers actually open you know when
they're more in this this bud light
stage here that's when you cut them to
put them into different kinds of eggs or
whatever you're cooking I will
have noticed that the deer if they do
eat this plant they will eat it when the
the buds are coming out not frequently
but they will do that Bluestar which is
a native plant the M Sonya tavern a
Montana this is kind of a plant is
promoted as a shade plant it also does
quite well um full Sun this is a plant
that flowers early in the summer and
usually what I do with this plan after
it flowers I just put it all the way
down to the ground and it will come back
in the summer thicker and nicer and it
gives you a nice thick green and a kind
of bushy kind of plant all the under
beiges we've tested well probably not
every species of Artemisia but we've
tried tried many of the art images and
they all been resistant to it the to the
deer the like plants like the tangerine
southernwood not a particularly
attractive plant it has a place in the
garden but it doesn't really flower and
it doesn't really do much it doesn't
even have that light white color that
the other species have up here but the
deer won't eat it and the Artemisia is
like glue the vichy anna white sage is a
very aggressive grower if you haven't
your garden it's going to spread quite a
bit shamini anna just it's just the
opposite it kind of barely survives the
winter sometimes polish castle i love
piles castle very dependable in the
garden that's one of those plants that
win it in the winter time there'll be
some damage on it but it rarely will
that plant died it just will maybe just
sections of it will die and it will come
back so but it's it's a great plan to
give you some of that fine textures from
the foliage as well as that light
colored leaves the Asclepius this was a
one of those those plants that I was
just so surprised we were maybe about 10
years ago sitting in a friend of ours
backyard and having a drink or whatever
and he had a field just an empty field
next to his property
and you know we could see the deer
walking through the field and you know
the conversation always goes around dear
and then I noticed that the butterfly
weed was just all over that film so with
that why aren't those deer eating those
butterfly weed so we tried this and
they're resistant the deer won't touch
this plant and it's very very pretty
garden ornament Allah just primarily in
the orange color but you can try the
other species both of these are belong
to that category for the pollinator
Gardens particularly butterfly gardens
so the the milkweed also a plant that
you don't see too frequently in gardens
but you should see more of because the
deer won't touch it and they are good
for for the pollinators callum entha
particular this white cloud other if
you've seen that some of you sell this
plant the white cloud it's really a
spectacular little plant blooms quite a
lot very easy to propagate if you're
into propagating your own plants you
could probably just take a kind of throw
it on the ground and it would root for
you so very interesting grower very
aggressive grower because it's in that
mint family which are so easy to grow
and so dependable so try the qella meant
as if you haven't tried those again this
is one of those plants like the grasses
I would be willing to you know say
without actually having tested all the
characters I would be willing to say
that these are probably all resistant to
deer this you know this weeping Brown
sage it's no wonder because the deer
probably think it's dead you know it
doesn't look like a dead plant but the
Carrick's are dependable plants the deer
stay away from there will be occasional
nibbling I think this is one of the
plants that they're trying to test to
see if they like it but they usually
stay away from this plant fox club one
of my favorites you know it's a it's a
true biennial but it it like some of the
other plants will act as a perennial
because it will recede itself and keep
coming up if you have a garden that you
don't mind a little site messiness this
is a planet when it receives it comes up
here and there you know it's not in the
same location every year but looks
really nice if you have a natural
can garden and don't forget that there
is a yellow form of the digitalis the
fox club grandiflora it's a little
shorter has a yellow flower and deer
stay away from that one too but very
poisonous you know this is the plant
that they make digitoxin from so if any
of you take heart medicine this is the
plant that they make that from so if you
if you chew on the leaves don't you want
to leave but but if you did your heart
would do a little palpitations there
euphorbia another group of plant that
the deer stay away from we've tried many
kinds of many of the species of
euphorbias and they seem to all be
resistant to the deer or the deer stay
away from them it's no wonder you know a
lot of the euphorbias kind of are toxic
you know people say for years that
poinsettias were poisonous they're not
but these are some of them are very bad
like the donkey tails purge this is one
of my favorite ones because it does get
its flower earlier in the summer with
that yellow you know just when you need
some color in the garden you get that
yellow flowers and then all summer long
you get the blue green grey foliage but
this is a plant all the euphoria is
really that you should be aware of that
when you when you're pruning them or
taking cuttings they do produce that SAP
and several people were allergic to that
they'll break out in a skin rash so if
you're out gardening with those and you
notice that your skin's getting red and
itchy it might be because of that plan
and one of my favorites the hellebores
if you need a plant for deep shade or
woodland garden we have this everywhere
the hellebores are everywhere and we've
been finding with this plant that they
do set their own seeds and they will you
you know repopulate their the forest
with just seedlings so we have these
everywhere the deer never touch these
plants lots of different colors now that
are available and if you haven't tried
these try these if you get them by
siblings of course they're going to take
a couple years before they flower
sometimes up to three or if you buy them
from plugs you're probably looking two
years lamee a strim this is not one of
my 95% plants the yellow Archangel
because the deer will come around in
this very early spring and they'll
nibble the plants usually wait before
they set right after they set bud so you
don't get the flower but you will keep
the the foliage this cultivar herman's
pride however the deer tend to stay away
from that's more clumpy it's not it's
not a trailer it's more of a clumpy
plant and the deer don't seem to like
that one as much as the regular true
species I'm not sure why but that's
that's what happens it's cousin lame iam
blame him and mainly a strim they used
to be the same genus but then taxonomist
realized that they were two different
plants lane IAM or even more dependable
than the lane me a strim rarely do you
see plants a deer excuse me rarely do
you see deer eating these plants and
this is a good shade plant and also it
does OK in full Sun but it's mostly a
shade plant and as you can tell just
from these cultivars you can get a lot
of flower variety you can also get a lot
of foliage diversity and so there you
can have all kinds of cultivars and you
learn and do very nicely with this
lavenders you know or one of the very
most popular pants state dears do stay
away from this we have some lavender
fields on the eastern end of Long Island
that people come in and they'll pay
eight dollars and fifty cents just to
walk through the lavender field and this
time of year they're blooming and then
they have once the flowers dry out they
sell the dried flowers people always
complain about this plant dying in the
garden but you have to remember with
lavenders they're one of the last things
to come out in the spring so they do get
woody stems and people will be out in
the garden other things are going to be
grown and they look at the lavender and
they'll they'll think that the plant is
dead but don't you know just be patient
with that plan it will probably leave
out for you but the foliage is great in
you know the great green color the
ligularia is lots of legal areas to use
these are also shade plants you can you
know they do very dependable they don't
like to dry out
and I've learned we don't we don't have
rear gation other than when I'm out
there with the hose so when they're dry
they'll just go flat but they do kind of
pop back interesting kind of yellowish
flowers that Othello has that orange
yellow flower I'm not sure if I like
that color but that's about the only
colors that you can get with these of
with this particular genus mints all the
mints this is another example where we
as humans eat mints or we use them in
drinks like mojito time and but the deer
won't touch him okay it don't you wish
that they kind of ate some of these
plants because they're so invasive they
spread everywhere if you do grow the
mint you might want to put them into a
pot because once they're in the ground
they're everywhere and as Paul mentioned
the daffodils all the daffodils are or
disliked by the deer for some reason but
you will notice some people say to me
all you know my gaff adele's have been
nibbled by the deer well remember when
that when the daffodils are flowering
early summer late spring whatever you
want to call it you know there are
babies around the baby fawns or there's
they may be extremely hungry after that
winter and they're going to taste taste
those buds but once they find out that
they don't like them they leave them all
the cat nips the cat mints dependable
deer will stay away from these plants
they get beautiful blue flowers and
early summer nice bushy plants
dependable this is a plant very similar
to the Blue Star that once it's done
blooming just I just whacked the thing
back and it's going to fire for you a
second time in the summer a very nice
plant the little aggressive this too
will recede and come up different places
and if you have cats some nice little
kitty drugs to give to your cat oregano
you know people don't think about
oregano as an ornamental too much but
you know right now the oreganos down in
Long Island are flowering we have all
kinds of flyers their whites and pinks
and kind of these purple colors you know
people usually think of oregano just as
a culinary herb something that you're
going to use when you're making pizzas
or if you're making sauce but you know
consider this as an ornamental in your
garden because they they do have pretty
flowers and they were actually used
cut flowers in by some farm stands the
pack of Sanders are great very
dependable the one that most people
think of is the pachysandra terminalis
just the regular old traditional
pachysandra it's cheap and does well in
shade full shade it spreads by rhizomes
but don't forget it's cousin the natural
species that Pakistan drew procumbens
which is also quite in resistant to dear
dependable it doesn't grow anywhere as
quickly as terminalis but it will add a
nice addition as somewhat deciduous is
kind of semi deciduous the foliage will
turn this kind of bronze purple color in
the fall and then also it does flower in
the spring not not spectacular flowers
but interesting okay okay yeah just kind
of here stop three minutes I haven't
gotten to the woodies yet but that's
okay we're all green has been we'd
rather have her bation yes penes very
good very dependable dear stay away from
them they don't even nibble on these and
of course you know in the garden they're
always fun to see come onto the ground
in the spring that is purple the purple
stamens are kind of very interesting
color addition to your garden of course
you know the penes they do need state to
hold up the flyers but but they're well
worth the energy Kowalski's I don't know
Hardy perhaps user up here dude there
are okay the hardy appear okay so a lot
of great great color again in the
foliage and then they get there pretty
light blue flowers another native plant
they may ample a beautiful plant you
know flyers then it gets the little
fruit on it that some people make jam
out of and then bout an out out right
now in a long island they're mostly
dying back they usually die before the
end of summer but dear won't touch these
plants Seattle use this is another
culinary herb that we use a lot right
the just the sage that we use in
stuffing and soups and all kinds of
things people grow it as an early
but don't forget that it has a
spectacular flower in about the same
time that the cap nips our cat mints are
flowering early summer they get this
blue coloring they're covered with blue
flowers a really hardy plant dependable
this is another one that once it's done
bloom when I cut it all the way back to
the ground and then you get this great
you know this great gray green foliage
for the summer in that particular
location Santa Lynas they're both deer
will eat these plants the kind of fun
plants they because these are kinds of
plants that if you're into shaping up
little topiaries you know if you have
like way too much free time on your
hands you can do that with these plants
lamb's ear are great again another one
with this whitish gray foliage and
people have often asked me if they if we
think that it's because of this white
coloration there's what keep deer way I
don't really know but it does seem to be
that there are a lot of plants that have
kind of a whitish gray foliage that deer
don't eat feverfew this is a plant
that's everywhere in our gardens in the
shade garden and the Sun garden it
recedes itself and it comes back
dependably every year and the deer never
touch it if you've ever smelled it you
probably know why they stay away from it
time don't forget you can never have
enough time and so this is true with a
plant also all the times again I haven't
tried all the species of time but I'd be
willing to say that the deer don't touch
these at all anyway periwinkle would
it's pretty dependable and evergreen a
good shade plant okay mr. Underwood is I
just have a few woody's buddleia do you
don't touch this plant but I know what
somebody in this audience going to say
to me it's invasive right people this is
good it's not on the invasive plant list
but it's going to get there Woodley has
come in white and purple and
a blue-colored so that's why nor up
there is doing this breeding work with
vitex vitex is a good replacement for
the Buddha Leah it looks almost exactly
like it except it has these marijuana
like leaves that that are not like
bloodless they don't have the same
effect you know we try to smoke them but
it just doesn't take but nor you know
what if we can get that kind of
marijuana kind of activity that might
not be so bad but every still buy tix
it's not supposed to be Hardy up here in
Ithaca but we notice that at Cornell
plantations last year they planted
several plants and they all live the
winter of course it was a mild winter
but we'll see what happens but this is
typically a plant for more warmer zone 7
Long Island zone 7 boxwoods we mentioned
boxers Paul mentioned boxford earlier
too dear won't eat it but yes there is
that disease problem but Marjorie there
are certain cultivars that are resistant
right to the the boxer Dwight is that
what your great of the same disease Oh
yikes yeah oh that's too bad but marks
woods dear won't touch the boxwood a lot
of different clubs words but we we have
several in our own personal garden and
some of them just they are wonderful
looking they don't get affected by any
kind of disease the junipers a lot of
the junipers are resistant to deer but i
won't say every junipers so look on the
list i have the list of the ones that
are and one of my favorite native plants
of course is the bayberry this is a plan
it's it's kind of a deciduous plant that
we grow a lot Long Island because it's
very drought tolerant it also tolerate
salt water don't forget that the
bayberry is dioecious so you have female
plants and male plants and if you want
these pretty berries you're gonna have
to get the females and then the tree
peony also there's a difference between
tea tree peony and the herbaceous peony
this one is a woody and you don't want
to cut this one down in the fall if you
cut this one down the fall you cutting
the stem off and you're cutting up
wires off for next year so so the tree
peony don't prune that back to the
ground please and I think so we should
cut it short you think okay so I do
before we get to the very end I don't
want to mention that we are organizing
this eco tour in may if anybody's
interested see me about it it's a 11
days and the Galapagos I've done this
before and it's the most wonderful
experience of your life and it's not
it's not a vacation every day we have in
the morning we get up at six we leave at
six and we hiked for three hours on a
different Island and then we snorkeled
for about three hours and then at the
end of the day we hike again so it's not
for the faint of heart but if you're
interested in something that would be
one of the most exciting experiences of
your life please come see me and I guess
we don't really have much time but I
will be out in the bluegrass Lane this
this afternoon if you have questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu